moi avec mon jeu on a vraiment un bon
feeling à aucun moment je regrette de
l'avoir adopté faux j'ai acheté une
laisse pour les chats mais je comprends
pas pourquoi ça existe genre de truc
veux qu'ils refusent absolument plus
tard promener on dirait qu'en fait je
promène son cadavre
[Musique]
c'est bon j'ai trouvé une solution
maman chat il y a un truc qu'il apprécie
vraiment faire c'est miauler près de 4
millions de fois par jour pour aucune
raison
par contre au moment où tu dois partir
je suis bien en speed et que je
l'appelle pour vérifier s'il est là il a
vraiment là l'intelligence de ne plus
violer du tout ce gros con cergy cergy
cergy je gueule plus là toute façon moi
j'arrive pas bien les ducs et mon chat à
chaque fois qu'il fait une connerie à la
fois je dispute mais en même temps je le
trouve trop mignon alors je fais plein
de bisous et il doit rien capté pourquoi
tu as volé mon petit bout de jambon
mais qu'est ce qu'il y aura comme je ne
comprends pas c'est bien c'est pas bien
mais les chats ils ont une façon de
penser qu'on peut pas comprendre par
exemple je vais acheter un jouet pour
chat d'une valeur inestimable
parfaitement sophistiqué il n'y jouent
près de zéro seconde
par contre il a trouvé ce ce bout de
plastique issu d'un paquet de gâteaux et
ça pour lui c'est vraiment la plus
grosse éclate du monde tu vois c'est
vraiment très très drôle
[Applaudissements]
kazaa
mais
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant parce que quand tu as un
chat et que tu reçois des invités très
vite tu te rends compte de qui habitués
à avoir un chat et qui ne l'est pas oula
oula
j'ai le chat qui vient sur moi de la
direccte tu dis que tu dis rien
hype et ses griffes là il en train de
griffe et à y perd ses poils en plus
j'étais allergique avant quand j'étais
petit il en train de me donner des coups
là voilà dans ma famille on avait un
hamster d'ailleurs je vais demander si
un jour je rentre chez moi et que mon
chat est décédé
qu'est ce que je fais du corps où je le
mets
[Musique]
ce qui est quand même très pratique avec
un chat c'est que le matin il peut te
réveiller ça fait fonction réveil
par contre c'est une heure complètement
aléatoire
[Musique]
pourquoi tu m'a réveillé il est 8 heures
je suis désolé je n'ai pas de zéro
en tout cas malgré ces petits problèmes
sans importance avoir un chat c'est un
vrai bonheur moi mon chat je vous donne
plein d'amour et il sait me le rendre
tu veux l'être promener ce message n'a
aucun rapport
depuis quelques temps il ya
l'application norman fait des vidéos qui
est sorti pour les téléphones de type
cellulaire
il ya déjà plein de gens qui l'ont
téléchargée et qui ont mis une bonne
note alors merci c'est cool certains se
demandent peut-être à quoi ça sert bah
en fait c'est pour recevoir mes vidéos
directement à la seconde où elle sort tu
peux consulter toutes mes anciennes
vidéos
je peux aussi envoyer plein de petits
messages en poche que j'écris moi même
avec mon petit doigt
il ya une sandbox où il ya plein de sons
rigolos de faire des blagues à traiter
cooper est aussi plein de petites
plaisanteries caché dans l'application
parce que j'aime bien je me mis à
rigoler et elle est totalement gratuite
pour tous nous voilà vous pouvez la
télécharger
à bientôt